[Music]
this morning on the dish a milestone for
one of the nation's largest restaurant
groups
rich mel-min opened his first venue
chicago's rj grunts 50 years ago
since then his lettuce entertain you
dining group has grown to include
60 brands and 130 restaurants across
more than
a dozen states i sat down with mel-min
in that first restaurant
on a street that now bears his name to
learn the secrets of his company's
success
i mean is this what it looked like this
was it yeah this was it
the walls are the same the floor is the
same it didn't change much
chicago's rj grunts opened in june of
1971.
it was just a hip casual fun type of
place that drew
a terrific crowd
50 years later the memories are still
vivid for co-founder rich mellman
it was his first restaurant with partner
jerry orzoff
and you never forget your first it's
very special the first one is very it's
like your first love
and for mel-min quite literally where he
fell
in love with his wife of 45 years martha
who joined us as we reminisced on a
recent visit i was standing here and
jerry came up to me
and said you know you're so crowdy said
anybody you want to meet
yet you know i said there's a girl
standing right over there you see that
one
and i'd walk around r.j grunts in the
early days
and if there was a cute girl there i'd
remember what she ate
more than i'd remember her do you
remember what she ate that night
i don't i really don't and he wasn't the
only one
and it kind of must have been true love
because i have not a clue what i ate
before starting then raising his own
family in the restaurant business
mel-min grew up in it his mom was a
waitress his dad a restaurant owner
do you remember the moment when you
realized that you wanted to go into the
restaurant business
yeah it certainly was pushed along by me
flunking out of college
so i fell back into working in
restaurants
often you know when you get good at
something you wind up liking it
and i i got real good at it hopefully we
could have a party
mel-min worked for his dad and saved his
money but when he tried to buy into the
business
his dad turned him down mel-min soon set
off on his own
but struggled to find investors until a
friend
suggested jerry orzoff his mother was
also a waitress
and we talked about how rough
they had had it and we said when we were
dreaming about the type of restaurant
we'd like to do let's make it the type
of place
where our moms would have felt great to
work at
the duo would spend the next decade
developing restaurants together
even after orzoff's death in 1981 the
culture he'd created with mel-min
lived on in the let us entertain you
brand there's a very important word
that's caring
and it's caring about the customer
caring about the food
caring about the service and a very
important thing is caring about yourself
we coach a lot you know you have to be
nurturing
and i like to think that's what we're
like as an organization we're nurturing
still based in chicago it's nearly
impossible to walk the streets there and
not stumble into a lettuce entertaining
restaurant
with 130 nationwide and 60 concepts
there's a wide variety of food in the
portfolio
with some of mel-min's favorites
tempting us during our interview
over there by you that's muhammara it's
a turkish
dish pulled chicken nachos one of the
biggest sellers and this is a prawn dish
prawns and lemon and some herbs
this is a carrot cake that martha
experimented with over the years and we
served it at rj's first birthday
and the kids wanted to put it in their
first restaurant
and i said oh i'm not sure if it'll be a
big seller
so much i know it's the biggest seller
they have for dessert
that first restaurant for the kids was
hub 51
launched by sons rj and jared who along
with their sister molly
worked their way up in the family
business rj now serving as president
molly and jared executive partners
what's the best piece of advice
that your dad has given you as you move
forward in this industry
something he always said growing up was
find your passion and then work your
hardest at it he never put
a lot of pressure on us to be in the
business you know you don't always have
to be the best at
anything but you can always hustle when
you're not trying your best is when
you're not going to be successful
i think he's great at always pushing us
to try to make things
even better even when things are going
great he always says there's there's
room to
improve it's really tender i don't know
if you just had to bite the head
yeah it's like this isn't spicy to me
okay good
for you to have your children in your
business
what does that mean what a blessing if
they
didn't have the talent didn't have the
drive didn't have the confidence to do
it
i would talk to them about trying
something else but make no mistake
mel-min isn't done personally helping to
build the let us entertain you legacy
i tried retirement i didn't enjoy it
take sundays off i
take vacations but i think
it would be hard for me to just not do
restaurants and
i don't have any other real hobbies you
love it i do i
love it and your kids are in it and it's
this is family yeah
and no surprise when reflecting on a
half-century anniversary
the man who started that family with
mel-min is very much
on his mind if you were having this meal
and you can have it with anyone past or
present
who would it be
jerry yeah my best friend
yeah i would love to um
share this with you to jerry for sure
so sweet danny this family was wonderful
the love between them
the energy the way they work together
and you can feel that in their
restaurants
we brought you the carrot cake from
martha okay and so
and cheers to let us entertain you in 50
years
exactly